[Música]
vamos a pasar ahora a nuestro siguiente
tema en directo a América y lo hacemos
hablando con nuestro primer invitado del
día la misión de la ONU encargada de
verificar la implementación de los
acuerdos de paz en Colombia con la ex
guerrilla de las FARC entregó Hace
algunos días un reporte preocupante que
alerta sobre retrocesos en la
construcción de paz en una variedad de
territorios a la par aumenta la
violencia en el país y no se ven grandes
avances en la paz total del presidente
de Gustavo Petro vamos al análisis con
Jorge mantilla quien es investigador de
temas de conflicto y de crimen
organizado Muchísimas gracias señor
mantilla y Bienvenido a directo a
América
Buenos días Muchas gracias por la
invitación mire el último informe de la
misión de la ONU que se realizó entre el
27 de marzo y el 28 de junio dejó como
conclusión una serie de alertas sobre el
cumplimiento de los acuerdos de La
Habana se registraron por dar algunas
cifras casi 20.000 desplazados forzados
y
entre otros entre otras cifras de que
son preocupantes como el asesinato
afirmante y a líderes Cuáles son los
peligros que enfrenta actualmente la
implementación Y y una segunda pregunta
por qué le ha costado tanto a un
gobierno a fin con Los acuerdos de La
Habana
bueno las principales riesgos de la
implementación ahorita en este nuevo
contexto de paz total tienen que ver con
la pérdida del control territorial que
ha tenido el estado en estos años de
diferentes lugares del país eso ha
provocado no solamente un crecimiento y
una expansión de los grupos armados sino
la confrontación entre estos grupos que
llevó al país pues hasta en una crisis
humanitaria como la que estamos
atravesando actualmente sin embargo este
nuevo gobierno a pesar de su política de
paz total y de que recientemente
promulgó una nueva política de seguridad
no ha sido capaz de contener estas
tendencias relacionadas con el
desplazamiento forzado con el
reclutamiento y con otras formas de
violencia Pues que se están
recrudeciendo en el país
mire otro indicador importante es uno
que entrega indepace que siempre está
haciendo los reportes sobre estos temas
y nos está hablando de que con corte a
la de tres de julio de este año se
registró el asesinato de al menos 375
líderes sociales y como le mencionaba en
la primera pregunta más de 60 firmantes
de paz la mayoría situados
específicamente en el departamento de
arauca qué decir sobre estas cifras que
nos hablan de un gran retroceso después
de la firma de un acuerdo que fue
considerado histórico a nivel mundial
Sí por supuesto aquí hay un desafío
enorme que tiene que ver con la
protección de la población civil
particularmente de ciertas comunidades
porque este contexto del conflicto
actual está caracterizado por unas
guerras mucho más locales
peleadas entre grupos también cada vez
más fragmentados entonces el desafío de
la paz total tiene que ver No solamente
con desescalar el conflicto entre el
estado y los grupos armados a través por
ejemplo de mecanismos como los heces al
fuego que se están implementando en la
actualidad sino lograr detener la
violencia entre los grupos armados para
hacer eso el estado tiene que retomar la
iniciativa militar y recuperar el
control territorial de estos lugares en
donde hoy gobiernan los grupos armados
en diferentes partes del país es el caso
que estamos viendo por ejemplo en chocó
actualmente con una confrontación ya de
de larga Data entre el eln y el clan del
Golfo que el estado ha sido incapaz de
tener y que tiene hoy ha hecho con una
crisis humanitaria con cerca de nueve
mil personas confinadas bueno pese a
esta posición
y a este con
el gobierno de Gustavo Petro firmó un
decreto que ordenó la suspensión de las
operaciones ofensivas de la fuerza
pública en contra del grupo criminal eln
en el marco de estas negociaciones que
se desarrollan se espera que haya un
cese el fuego entre el tres de agosto y
el 29 de enero y ahora le pregunto Qué
efecto tendrá este pacto sobre esa
violencia ya existente y usted nos está
describiendo
pues lo ideal sería que de alguna manera
acompañado de una mayor presencia del
estado por ejemplo en las zonas donde
leen está particularmente la frontera
Colombo Venezolana en el departamento de
arauca y el departamento de norte de
Santander sin embargo una de las
características o de los detalles de ese
es el fuego que es particularmente
preocupante Es que además de las
operaciones ofensivas el estado se
compromete a no hacer más inteligencia
contra el eln Entonces es cesa su
capacidad de investigación criminal por
ejemplo además se compromete a detener
las desmovilizaciones individuales o
colectivas de miembros del eln que
quieran salirse del grupo y pensaría uno
pues que eso tiene un inconveniente
táctico en términos de la confrontación
pues con este grupo armado que si bien
está en una mesa de negociación pues
sabemos por su trayectoria histórica que
su voluntad Paz digamos puede no ser la
más genuina Y eso tendrá que demostrar
el proceso mismo bien sobre este tema
seguro tendremos mucho más que hablar
porque entre agosto y septiembre se va a
realizar el cuarto ciclo de
conversaciones tendrá que darse un
balance sobre lo que ha sucedido con
estas negociaciones que se adelantan con
el eln pero para el cierre quisiera
hablarle de otra iniciativa o otras
iniciativas paralelas que adelanta
Gustavo Petro Y es que ha sido criticado
por traer la paz desde muchos frentes
sin concentrarse efectivamente una de
las iniciativas que tiene la han apodado
pagar por no matar y ha recibido muchas
críticas realmente se llama jóvenes de
paz y lo que plantea es entregar
subsidios mensuales a los jóvenes en
situación de vulnerabilidad Usted qué
opina de esta iniciativa
bueno estos programas Gustavo Petro
implementó jóvenes en paz cuando fue
alcalde de Bogotá y aquí lo fundamental
es
enmarcar estos programas dentro de una
estrategia más amplia de prevención de
la violencia por supuesto los incentivos
si no se focalizan bien si no se hace un
seguimiento si no se evalúa el impacto
esos incentivos pueden terminar siendo
incentivos perversos entonces hay normas
preguntas sobre cómo se van a focalizar
cómo se van a escoger estos jóvenes Cuál
es el seguimiento que se le va a hacer y
cómo Este programa de jóvenes en paz se
enmarca entre una estrategia más amplia
particularmente de seguridad que lleve a
reducir los índices de criminalidad lo
que estamos viendo en este momento es un
gobierno que abre diferentes
conversaciones de paz no solamente con
grupos armados sino también con grupos
delincuenciales urbanos Como sucede en
el caso de Buenaventura en el caso de
Quito o en el caso de Medellín y uno
espera que este programa de jóvenes en
paz hiciera parte como de una política
más amplia habrá que esperar a ver qué
impactos tiene Cómo se hace la
focalización insisto y cuál es el
seguimiento que le va a hacer el
gobierno a este programa pues mire Jorge
Lamentablemente Nos quedamos sin tiempo
pero le agradezco mucho es Jorge
mantilla investigador de temas de
conflicto y de crimen organizado y como
usted nosotros continuaremos haciendo el
seguimiento a los procesos adelantados
contra la violencia en Colombia Muchas
gracias muchas gracias Buen día a
nuestros televidentes los invitamos a
seguir con nosotros en directo América
hacemos una pequeña pausa pero ya
volvemos con más
[Música]